behind the cgi of venom there are stunts
practical effects and a ton of
impressive acting
venom is a really visually exciting
movie to watch especially because of the
wild and shocking transformation we see
eddie undergo the complex villain is
brought to life thanks to some truly
remarkable cgi
behind the scenes is just as
action-packed as the final cut of these
films
venom 2 definitely doesn't hold back on
the wild action and impressive cgi work
these tendrils have a total life of
their own in this shot but behind the
scenes the carnage arm grab looks pretty
different
instead of real tendrils wires and
harnesses did the heavy lifting to make
sure the cameras captured what they
needed
the restricted spin around while being
held by wires looks far from comfortable
to deal with but it was well worth it
considering just how epic the final
result looks
while tom hardy gives a great
performance the shape-shifting
transformation we see on screen from man
to super villain is all thanks to
painstakingly detailed cgi work the vfx
team actually created animations for
every single frame we see
while it took a lot of time and
expertise it was the best way to make
sure the transformation looked as slick
and real as it does
every layer of the detailed animation
images contributes to making venom's
interactions with people and the world
looks so convincing
one of the coolest scenes in the first
venom takes to the streets with this
massive mess of black tendrils moving
from flat on the ground to a powerful
stance
while his movements look flawless in the
final cut behind the scenes was a very
different story as the actors were hard
at work to perfect choreography to
properly map out the movements the cgi
team needed the best footage to work
with to bring venom to the screen in
such a central and powerful way
in the end they definitely were not
disappointed
the second venom film features a pretty
massive leap onto the hood of a car
that's made to look like an effortless
motion in post-production but as we can
see behind the scenes a lot of prep had
to be done and safety measures had to be
considered for this superhuman moment
seeing just how intense the stunt is
without cgi is a great example of how
much acting the performers need to do to
appear as though these daunting tasks
are totally effortless
venom let there be carnage is filled
with plenty of shooting scenes which of
course are no match for the creature the
drama of it all is still as present
without cgi considering the high stakes
and loud noises
all the flashes of light and details to
support the storytelling are courtesy of
added effects since they were just
shooting blanks on the set
the living room sequence in the first
venom film is one of the most intense
battles in part because of the power
imbalance one versus three hardly seems
fair except for when the one actually
turns out to be pretty fine on his own
thanks to the power of venom the cgi in
this scene is key for showing the
surprising and powerful transformation
tom hardy goes through a whole lot of
stage combat and practical effects
contributed to executing the battle so
well
as he slowly discovers the sheer amount
of power he has tom hardy looks a bit
crazy staring down at his fist as if it
were a monster and to be fair with the
cgi monstrous is a pretty good
descriptor for what we end up seeing
part of what makes the cgi so effective
is the fact that hardy performed each of
these scenes with 100 commitment
especially when he was embodying venom
the motorcycle chase scene is one of the
most complicated sequences shot for the
first film and an epic point of action
while the scene itself only lasts a few
minutes before filming even commenced
planning happened for months to make
sure it could all be carried out
efficiently while making sure the epic
footage was still captured what's even
crazier is that the whole chase was
actually filmed and cgi was what managed
to weave the whole scene together
seamlessly and with impressive detail no
less
stunt doubles took over for the actual
riding on the streets robbie madison and
joe dryden performed legendary motorbike
stunts considering all the planning it's
no surprise about 40 cars ended up being
used and inevitably destroyed over the
course of filming while cgi did amp up
the look of this nose dive through
flames stunt performer dryden really did
whip through fire to make sure the team
had the best shot they could get to be
perfected of course with special effects
we get to see the venom tendrils in full
force when they bring hardy's character
to safety well as safe as someone can be
whipping through the city on a
motorcycle
filming in studio saw the actor
maneuvered by a harness to move from
floating in the air to regaining control
but the moment cgi came into play was
when the scene really came to life
robbie madison looked dangerous straight
in the face when he was preparing for
the huge jump on the famously steep
bullet hill this was actually the
performer's very first jump in america
and was it ever a cool one
since the team was limited in how many
times the stunt could be performed they
needed cgi to make sure the scene looked
good in the movie after three stunt
jumps madison was able to really hear
the sounds of the cars crashing and the
intensity of the whole experience hit
him the effects added in post made the
jump look even more legendary
for the wicked motorcycle sandwich the
performers were in real cars and hardy
was actually on top of a motorcycle but
the whole scene was filmed while the
vehicles were stationary filming with a
blue screen behind them hardy had some
good opportunities to really perform
well on the motorbike and all the while
not having to worry about his own safety
the cgi fills in the blank adding the
scenery and effects to amplify the
intensity of this moment
this motorcycle slide is nothing short
of impressive the two weeks spent to
create a specially designed metal plate
for the motorcycle to attach to in order
to safely whip around with such speed
was well worth the effort the experience
of filming was pretty wild and the final
result adds a really cool unexpected
moment to the whole sequence
the visual details of venom really
complete the masterpiece
this apartment fight was pretty wicked
and included the vicious weight throwing
move
luckily the actors weren't in any actual
dangers since there weren't any real
weights on the set cgi isn't just used
for big explosions and out of this world
creatures sometimes generating images
for more typical or practical effects is
what's needed
with major throws come a whole lot of
wires and harnesses
while in the first movie we see exactly
what outer force throws him around
behind the scenes it almost looks a bit
more like magic since hardy was hooked
up to wires and harnesses making sure
the tricky stunts could be filmed safely
it looks incredible in rehearsal so it's
no surprise that the final product is a
gem as well
slamming into the wall over and over
again can't have been the most
comfortable experience for the actor
though
there were a fair number of window jumps
in the first venom film some simple
leaps from inside a corridor shattering
glass in the midst and in other cases
epic leaps through the air in both cases
cgi played a key role filling in the
scenery and making performers look like
they're really soaring
especially when it came to all the venom
detailing
the cgi in these films is brilliant
and venom really is like no other we've
seen before the sheer amount of
practical effects and actual stunts
combined with the slick vfx make these
films seriously impressive feats which
cgi moment surprised you most
[Music]